it's amazing how long 12 years in the
NFL my gosh third overall pick of the
2008 draft joining us from the Atlanta
Falcons courtesy of our friends at
Gatorade beat the heat program he is
Matt Ryan how are you Matt
I'm doing great rich how you doing I am
great how's life how's life it's very
good I cannot complain what is what is
amid what is mid-june when you're not
doing stuff with Gatorade look look like
for you Matt Ryan uh you know it's a
little bit of family time some working
out and training and then you know
sprinkling in a little golf a little
golf in there to get the get the fix in
before before training camp start
give me your game what's your handicap
what's your handicap playoff a1
currently but it's not it wasn't pretty
you know it's not pretty right now Matt
Ryan it is you are not allowed as a
human being to say I play awful one but
it's not pretty right now that is just
can't allow it I won't allow it
I'm telling you you wouldn't want me as
a partner it's not necessarily on but
maybe you know I I would bring at least
18 pieces of candy to that partnership
I could I could do that what's the best
round you've ever you've ever had what's
your lowest score I've never been in the
60s to be honest with the the best I've
ever shot at 70 and I've done that a
hansel of times but I got to get over
that hump and go low one time so what
was the best player you've ever played
with from the NFL who's the guy that you
would want to partner up with because
he's got a great step Tony Romo is back
when I was young playing played in a
little bit of the event out at Lake
Tahoe and to watch him play he's got
some serious game he he can play and
that would be the one guy that I would
take his game that I have I've been
around and have played well is there any
comparison of the concentration level to
play golf with with the NFL with
pre-snap
Reed's pre-snap this and then figure out
in real time obviously you're not going
to get physically hit playing golf but
I'm just wondering if there's any
comparison in terms of the concentration
level required to play I think there is
you know I think
the emotional hits are pry forcing it
really it can damage your ego for sure
you think you're playing well and then
all of a sudden Wham
but I think you know in making decisions
and then you know trusting the decisions
that's make and trying to let it rip I
think that's probably the biggest
carryover between the two you got to
trust you know what you see and I feel
like in football I'm playing my best
when when I'm trusting my gut my
instincts and probably the same can be
said in golf when you kind of just see
what you want to do and you let it go
that's usually when I play the best all
right let's talk a little football right
here let's talk a little ball the
competition committee just an hour ago
they unanimously passed the rules to
make it all the fact it's happening
instant replay is gonna be able to be
used for offensive and defensive pass
interference Matt Ryan do you like that
I think so you know I think I like it I
like the intent of them trying to to get
it right if they have the opportunity to
do it I think it's a wait-and-see kind
of thing how's it going to shake out how
are they gonna you know how are they can
handle it but I like the intent I like
where their heads at you know and going
there and trying to to make it with the
technology at hand that the best it can
be so let me just bounce off something
that I saw just the other day at the NFL
Network symposium where al River on the
head of NFL refs gave a presentation on
this Matt do you remember the week 15
Kansas City Chiefs Los Angeles Chargers
game where Phillip Rivers flipped it to
Mike Williams and back-to-back plays for
a touchdown then a two-point conversion
to win it do you remember that yeah okay
the play before those two was when Matt
Williams Mike Williams was interfered
with win the endzone and it set the ball
up on the one-yard line that under the
new rules of replay with instant instant
replay would pass interference according
to Al River on the defensive pass
interference call would have stood is
called bought because anything that is
reviewable can be replay right offensive
pass interference would have been called
by replay it would have been offsetting
penalties your thoughts
that was our response but that's what's
coming because OPI is now reviewable so
anytime that you're reviewing for DPI
OPI could be called as well and vice
versa
that may be coming do you like that I
like I like the intent of trying to get
whatever is happening on the field
correct you know and that's why I kind
of have the wait-and-see let's wait and
see you know how this is actually going
to be called how much they're going to
change when they go to review its to me
kind of let's get a feel for for what
it's going to look like and how it's
going to shake out but I like the intent
of if something is egregious and it's
missed of being able to correct that
matt ryan here on the Rich Eisen show
some old friends are back on the staff
jerk cutter Mike Mularkey what are you
what are your thoughts on how that's
going to affect the offense that you are
at the controls of Matt well you know I
love it I we had a lot of success during
my time with both of those coaches and I
think Mike coming back and coaching the
tight ends is is great for us he brings
a mindset and a level of detail that's
going to make our staff better and he's
going to make our position group at the
tight end position better and then I
think with Dirk you know he's a guy that
you know I have a ton of respect for
really enjoyed the three years that I
you know I worked with him and played
for him and then you know kind of hated
him for the four years he was in Tampa
and they were putting up huge numbers
going again I was always tough you know
so I like I like playing with him and
working with him better than I like
going against him so I'm happy he's back
in the building and excited about you
know what he's going to bring to our
offense and and his ability as a play
caller to put us in good situations
anything different do you think gonna be
as far as the the scheme and the
terminology that has stayed the same to
what we've been doing the last four
years so he is adjusted that but I think
with any with any play caller and with
any coordinator week to week and how
they gameplan and what they emphasize
and what
go to in certain situations is different
and Dirks definitely got a different
personality type then sock did and and
in a different flavor for what he likes
in certain situations - what's arced it
Matt Ryan Atlanta Falcons quarterback
here on the Rich Eisen show alright so
what are you doing with the Gatorade
beat the heat programs the 15th annual
what are you doing with these folks met
well you know this morning I was at a
Boys & Girls Club here in Atlanta and
it's really just to try and you know
educate kids on hydration we deal with
some some hot temperatures and and crazy
humidity here in the south and you know
it's trying to create an awareness for
for hydrating early making sure you're
getting in front of it letting them know
that you're losing more than just water
when you sweat you're losing
electrolytes and salt and all those
things and they need to be replenished
and so teaching them you know what's in
Gatorade and how it helps you and how it
benefits you and then also you know it
allows you to be outside and and to do
these healthy things and be active even
when it is hot outside so I think that
creating that kind of awareness and
keeping you know kids safe and helping
coaches and different people that are
out here you know with the kids in these
situations to me it's a no-brainer to
team up with them and create that
awareness to keep these kids safe and to
keep them healthy yeah and for more
information about Gatorades be TV
program fans can find heat safety tips
crucial heat safety tips as we're
getting ready for summer and school's
out and camps are going on at Gatorades
youtube channel while we're on the
subject of quenching thirst matt the the
whole concept of quarterback
beer-chugging
popped to the fore over the last four
weeks what did you think of aaron
rodgers beer-chugging attempt at the
Milwaukee Bucks playoff game a few weeks
ago Matt I'm like it it might have been
an IPA or something like that those IPAs
that's not easy to
different from from one of the light
beers so it is you know at 34 I'm not
checking many beers myself is a young
man's game
you know he was sitting that's obviously
he didn't let gravity help and also he
strikes me as a sipper like whenever
he's an alcohol drinker if he ever is at
any point in time he looks like he's a
sipper but uh folks like true Biscay
Holmes your buddy Stafford stepped up
and when it came to this so where do you
put yourself in this mix man where would
where would you rank yourself uh middle
of the road middle of the road really
first for sure maybe an eighteen or
ninth and say that maybe at 21 middle of
the road that's bottom third of the NFL
NFL starters really would you okay okay
I mean and that's why I'm wondering why
you would go by the name of Maddie I
smacked that's why I'm what I mean
that's a beer infused nickname would you
agree it doesn't fit anymore Matt are
you the natural coming back or are we
making a push for the natural here that
nickname that you've had for a long time
just just I like beer I do like right so
bunny comes to it though you just you're
not you're not slamming them back right
is what you're saying no I guess I'm
drinking responsibly okay you're
drinking something that would be
responsible something that would be a
natural light of some sort matter you're
what I'm drinking what are you drinking
in a long time you keep making my point
why won't you take the match room from
me man just why won't you do it I mean
how many times do I have to ask how many
times nobody else
[Applause]
are you aware I offered it to Stafford
your buddy did you that right yes well I
mean he that's a no man I gave him full
disclosure that it was a retread and
that you had rejected it because I know
you guys talk I know you guys you guys
are tight right he forgot to mention it
to me the last time I saw him I can't
believe that wasn't top of mind for him
okay so just just on behalf of all my
loved ones who are cringing right now
just tell me to move on Matt and I'll
move on just tell me to move on rich you
gotta move on you gotta move on I love
you but you gotta move on thank you Matt
thank you so much even if I gave you a
t-shirt or all right Matt I can take a
hint after nine years or so this has
been a fun chat thanks for thanks for
coming on brother when his training camp
opened for you what is that actually we
report the 21st in about a month oh wow
well hit him straight enjoy it thanks
for calling in it sounds like you got
your hands full behind you right there I
appreciate the call you got it thanks
rich always fun always fun he's right
back after this member for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app